[Música]
Hola Bienvenidos a migrantes el programa
semanal de France 24 sobre el Éxodo los
saluda Julieth riaño
[Música]
el tapón del darín es una selva tropical
lluviosa que comparte en Panamá y
Colombia y es la única ruta para el
tránsito terrestre de Sur a
Centroamérica en los primeros nueve
meses de 2022 más de 151 mil migrantes
cruzaron ese paso considerado el más
peligroso de América Latina nuestro
periodista Jorge Hurtado visitó la
provincia del Darién en Panamá y
conversó con algunos migrantes
sobrevivieron a la selva en estas
embarcaciones cientos de migrantes
arriban diariamente a su primer contacto
con la civilización tras cruzar el
daríen el trayecto más peligroso del
continente que divide Colombia y Panamá
willington Jiménez su esposa y su hija
acaban de vivir una de las experiencias
más temibles de su vida largas caminatas
por fango lobo montaña Barranco
personas
personas muertas que ni siquiera los
familiares saben si están allí o no
según las autoridades en Puerto limón
arriban cerca de mil extranjeros por día
la orden es llevar a estas personas
hacia un centro de acogida para
brindarles atención médica y comida
Néstor Pérez y su esposa Daniela también
sobrevivieron al Darién luego que la
crisis económica de Venezuela los
agobiara después de haber estado cerca
de la muerte invitan a reflexionar a
otros migrantes para que no hagan el
viaje tuve mamá madre dio oportunidad de
la muerte aquí en la cara mía Para
pasarle esa selva las montañas esas son
horrible a nadie a nadie muertos en la
selva personas tiradas que nadie sabe si
si lo van a recoger no lo van a recoger
dijeron demasiadas mentira incluso
cuando estábamos ahí mismo en la selva
camina en derechito por ahí queda dos
horas llegan pasaban 12 horas y nosotros
seguíamos caminando
luego de pasar otros problemas de
logística dentro de Panamá muchos entren
en desesperación por querer continuar su
camino como el venezolano osmarking
marquina quien partió desde Colombia
solo con su maleta con la que así
entregas a domicilio temiendo por el
nuevo gobierno es la segunda vez que
emigra si da miedo en pocas palabras
porque digamos que que venía haciendo lo
mismo que que Venezuela con con el
presidente que se desmontó Aunque me
critique Aunque me murmuren O sea me da
igual o sea en verdad sí comenzó
Venezuela cuando cuando vivía allá esta
entrevista es la prueba de vida para su
esposa e hijo que dejó en Colombia
en la estación San Vicente los buses
vienen y van con migrantes allí las
organizaciones humanitarias atienden las
heridas que dejó la selva pero el flujo
lo supera según las autoridades
panameñas en lo que va del año han
muerto 18 personas cruzando el Darién
solo en 2021 murieron 50 y quienes
sobreviven se llevan uno de los peores
recuerdos de sus vidas
entre los migrantes que cruzan el Darién
hay mujeres embarazadas familias con
niños e incluso menores que viajan solos
y aunque con el tránsito masivo las
autoridades han reforzado la seguridad
en la zona de frontera los riesgos se
multiplican para estos grupos de
personas esto encontró nuestro
periodista Jorge Hurtado
Marla Fernández y su hija de seis meses
sobrevivieron a la selva del Darién
cuenta que en su trayecto para llegar a
Estados Unidos debió ser auxiliada por
otros migrantes porque no tenía fuerzas
para cargar a su bebé
no Porque viven en la selva el desespero
de ver sufrir a mi niña porque si sufran
los niños sufren y bastante los que
dicen que los niños no sufren es mentira
los niños sufren mucho mucho mucho mucho
en esa selva y pues no no le des a
ninguna madre que meta sus hijos por esa
por esa selva
Marcos vitora mientras hacían su propia
travesía ayudó a mujeres y niños a salir
de la selva y caminando nos encontramos
un niño que la mamá me lo dio a mí para
llevar adelante
un poco de peso pesado pero no solo los
niños son vulnerables en este peligroso
viaje las mujeres también están
propensas a sufrir ataques sexuales gris
velis Oropeza además de ser estafada por
los coyotes estuvo cerca de ser abusada
Pues sí me sentí un poco incómoda porque
un indio me ofreció plata y no me
querían dejar salir de la playita porque
quería que yo me acostara con él y él me
iba a dar 200 dólares de verdad que sí
violan a mujeres si las violan es un
poquito complicado para nosotros las
mujeres yo tuve suerte gracias a Dios
pero su caso no es aislado Pese a que
las autoridades panameñas son
conscientes de los delitos argumentan
que lo impenetrable de la selva no les
permite actuar a tiempo contra los
criminales la denuncia que presentan
ellos son de robos por parte de
originarios pues del sector que se
aprovechan de la vulnerabilidad de estos
migrantes que vienen en ese afán de
llegar al a Norteamérica y Canadá en el
adicional Pues hay algunas femeninas que
presentan denuncias ante el Ministerio
Público de violación
las víctimas de la travesía son
incalculables no hay manera de tener un
registro de niños muertos o de mujeres
violadas el miedo a las amenazas de las
bandas violentas y decir que los hijos
quedaron muertos en la selva impide
obtener datos fidedignos es algo que los
migrantes prefieren borrar de su memoria
y continuar su camino
los datos de los servicios migratorios
de Panamá revelan un ingreso
récord de migrantes por sus fronteras en
2022 por lo que el país pide acciones
regionales urgentes para enfrentar este
Éxodo hasta que migrantes de France 24
los invitamos a comentar en nuestras
redes sociales con el hashtag migrantes
f24 sigan con más información en France
24 y France 24.com
[Música]